greetings [__] welcome to podcast
Ville the Church of what's happening now
is brought to you by my favorite
underwear in the world me on this you
heard me talk about them you know I'm a
big believer in their product and
they're the perfect balance of comfort
fit every man should have me undies and
every month they got new and exciting
prints that arrive at your door and a
fun little bag you'll even though you
think it's a little [__] surprise
when somebody you never know what's
going on me and these is great office
for my listeners all right the first
time purchases when you purchased me
undies you get 20% off and free shipping
listen me and these uses lens Inc micro
mount lowdown and their underwear its
sustainable source naturally saw a fiber
that is softer than cotton I love them I
wear them to jiu-jitsu they keep
everything dry they keep the nutsack
smelling good and everything is
beautiful me and these are so sure you
love their underwear they're gonna offer
you hundred-percent money-back guarantee
but do me a favor let's get this show
started go to me on these calm right now
slash Joey that's me I'm these calm
right now slash Joey to get you 20% off
your first pair free shipping and 100%
money back guarantee number two Lee
lives off these things and I love you
blue apron I think it's one of the best
ideas in the world you know why because
they're the number one leading milky
delivery service in the US and a lot of
people don't know about them
blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
why because their mission is to make
incredible home cooking accessible to
everybody they have a two-person meal
plan a family meal plan they got it all
if you got a question they'll solve it
for you what I want you to do is this
right now check out this week's menu
when you go to meet blue apron doctor go
to blue apron calm and just check out
this week's menu alright if you see
something you're like what I'm gonna do
is this I'm gonna get your $30 off your
first blue apron calm order by going by
blue apron calm slash Joey that's blue
apron calms last Joey trust me blue
apron it's a better way to cook kick
that [__] mealy
[__] John Osbourne and his finest
Rikki Rockett finally finally man that
[__] just make takes me back to like
kegger parties and like you know when I
was discovering all that stuff man Jesus
Christ back in your days in Pennsylvania
yeah yeah this all started in pencil
rain like I thought you know if you when
you meet somebody and you see their
music and you watch the videos over the
years you go okay this done on the
Sunset Strip
Ricky's from [__] Orange County the
other guy the singer is from [__] San
Francisco and they guitar players from
San Diego and when I read about you I'm
like these [__] guys are from
Pittsburgh
CiCi's from Brooklyn that the finalists
of the guitar player was between him
slash and some other [__] monster
yeah I went with CeCe you know yeah just
uh just a phenomenal story
millions of [__] records all over the
world world tours and now you know this
is all a t6 through 92 whatever part of
glam rock even even longer 19 little
longer and then all of sudden hey you
are 2017 well here's the thing you know
back in in PA we were pretty young guys
when we put this band together you know
19 20 21 years old and it was hard to
play bars I mean they didn't you know we
even if we could get in the door and
play that the the generation that was
frequenting bars were older you know
what I mean they were 25 30 35 you know
what I'm saying and you know so we're
appealing to kids so that's when we you
know we would play Maryland because the
drinking age was only 18 in Maryland at
the time so we did a lot of shows in
Maryland but then we're like well we
can't just play those same couple of
clubs over and over again so we started
to rent vv8 brilla let me try this in
English VFW halls skating rinks promote
our own concerts you know what I mean
and it would be all ages and we'd you
know and then we finally I mean we had
just done everything that we could do
back there out here was where Hard Rock
was happening it was where Motley Crue
rat kyo I mean all those bands were you
know I'm saying and so it made sense to
come here it made sense to come here New
York was not fertile for it that was
still wrapped up in the whole new wave
scene which was fine that's just not
what we were doing and Philly was like
vocal bands and it really wasn't a rock
scene too much I mean arguably
Cinderella came out of there but but out
here was where we needed to be and so we
moved out here in March of 84 I mean we
had like 2,500 bucks between the four of
us and we just came out and went for it
we're figuring if we're gonna sleep on
the sidewalk at least we'll be warm one
guy couldn't take it the guitar player
yeah he got his girl knocked up and you
know it just wasn't his
it just wasn't gelling all the way you
know what I mean like he's a super good
guy I talked to him once in a great
while and he's a really great guitar
player and I mean he went through all
those clubs with us in the early days
and really helped poison be what it is
but and variably it just wasn't the life
for him he did not like the late nights
and I mean we loved to party
you know what I mean I mean we we were
just all up in it we'd love to go out
every single night party till 2:00 in
the morning come back change into a pair
of jeans and then go out and put flyers
up all over town and then sleep till
noon and then rehearse and then do the
same thing over again and that's what we
did we just worked what you got to LA or
when you was doing well in Pennsylvania
we did we had jobs back in Pennsylvania
out here we made this our full-time job
we did dumb [__] like sell pencils for
you know yes all that [__] yeah but but
as far as like I mean we just made it
our full-time then we'd go to like
Covina West Covina and places like that
and play cover songs we were a band that
were we were reared on playing cover
songs you have to do that back east and
then you slip in some original material
out here it is an original circuit you
come out you play our original material
so we're like how are we going to make
money so
we go to the outskirts of Los Angeles or
even different like Arizona and and play
bars that we could play cover songs just
what we did in PA and we'd make money
that way and then we'd put it back into
our flyers and and our promotion and you
know we work really really really hard I
mean we were like the kind of guys that
if we all worked at the same restaurant
we would have owned it in a couple years
I mean we just had a hair up our ass we
were on fire
you know and we were determined really
really really determined what was the
first club you got into here on the
first place we ever played was Madame
Wong's West that's not there no whoa
she's not there anymore it's gone yeah
and who wouldn't like you and you it was
you guys motley crue who was well motley
crue was all mine they had played the
you us festival I mean they were well on
the way they were couple albums in by
the time they were like who did to us
because shot with the devil came on 83
84 yeah yeah we moved out here in March
of 84 so yeah they definitely had were
ahead of us and in rat and when we got
here they said you know it it was like
you know we were being told that that
music is getting really really really
heavy that's where it's going and if
we're gonna do anything we had to go
really heavy and we weren't we were a
rock and roll band I mean we were like
part Aerosmith part van Halen part kiss
part you know whatever you know we had
all those routes and and we liked
playing rock and roll so you know
influences Google growing up so mash
stuff died so much stuff I mean
everything from from Zeppelin to Mott
the Hoople to everything in between my
first concert my first concert believe
it or not was Herb Alpert and the
Tijuana brass or at the Allentown fair
so I love all kinds of music you know
and my dad was a trumpet player my mom
loved Elvis you know my sister was a
hippie she was nine years older than me
so she had Grateful Dead going and here
I came along you know when I made my
first record that I ever bought was deep
purple made in Japan
you know and still to this day highway
star and all those songs are just an Ian
Paice is this [__] I mean what a
drummer come on man and he still [__]
just takes it the [__] charmer just
Wow somebody was on him we were just did
there when they got back together that
video oh yeah tournament and I forget
what the name of the song was I'll tell
you one purple got patches yeah
something they did something recently
not recently a couple years back you
know I'd feel guilty because I have not
kept up with D pro but I saw deep purple
at the farm show arena in Harrisburg and
Tommy Bolin was playing guitar for them
it's when Blackmore left and Tommy
bilenda who was [__] of a nominal for
now I mean just another level I gotta
say some [__] Ritchie Blackmore's
always give me the [__] creeps I
can't lie the end he kids me and I've
seen him I saw him I think twice I saw
him in 82 when rainbow did the scorpions
break out black out yeah yeah yeah I saw
I saw that tour and I saw that I saw
that tour with Judas Priest donkus yeah
because I saw them awesome
it was the Scorpions and them rainbow
with Joe Lynn Turner who was really
Jolin Guido
yeah I'm close I'd Park New Jersey yeah
it's so [__] Turner sex hell of a
singer though dude you know he's still
out there he's still [__] doing it I
mean but did you see where Ritchie
Blackmore looks like that I haven't live
and seen him you know what I've never
wanted to meet him cuz I've heard stuff
about so I'm like I don't even you know
I don't try to meet people anymore
because I've been let down a few times
and I just don't even want to bother if
somebody wants to say hi to me I'm open
I'm really easy guy to get along with
but I people left me down man you know
and I just so I just like people you
looked up to you over the years you went
up to it earlier we're talking about
jiu-jitsu people versus musicians
musicians drive me nuts you jitsu people
or saw
so if somebody's a musician and a
jujitsu person they're usually fairly
solid because the jiu-jitsu part takes
over that [__] musician part so we
have 20 mutual friends but the main was
John John salami is his family and I
love John yeah he's he's he's a
misunderstood person
let me tell you some he's a great he's a
very very creative professional too bad
[__] yeah I love him with all my
heart I told met them three days a week
I call him names to that call them at
6:00 in the morning
you know I torment him and he gave me
for a birthday present a he gave Machado
seminar and uh and that's the first time
I saw you on the mat and I mean I was
struggling I was embarrassed to be there
I even popped like the shroom tech like
a pop tool so that made my heart even
worse like I was really struggling with
jujitsu and there's Dan Inosanto there's
you there's you know your professor now
just the fact that you put me in the
same sentence with Danny and a song it's
pretty amazing because he gets put in
the same sentence as Bruce Lee so I know
because I was you know thousand pounds
overweight and people come up to me
going hey put your foot here dude
everybody came over said you're doing
this you're a big guy do this you know
then and I left there like embarrassed
but at the same time I felt good but you
were great like you said something to me
about my arm put your arm here over here
you'll get more leverage I never forgot
that oh and then two weeks later I walk
into an airport and who's sitting there
like a lonely person with Rikki Rockett
and I go up to you I don't know if you
remember me from the seminar we were
delayed yeah yeah 11 hours got delayed
because there was a thunderstorm that we
landed and [__] we had to do an
emergency landing and somewhere in
Oklahoma yeah then they flew us into
Dallas yeah and in Dallas I caught the I
lost you at the airport right every man
from
I love you Ricki rocket but we gotta get
down and I lost you because we're all
we'll all switches flights and we didn't
know if we had to spend the night in
Dallas and yeah that now yeah yeah and I
love Italian Charlie no can you believe
I see him at a seminar I say two weeks
later he's the nicest [__] guy in the
world and in Hagen you mentioned Higgins
I loved Higgins Higgins you know I've
always said this I you know what what
doesn't what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger
except pagan he'll just kill you yes but
no I love a man he's just uh he's just
such a free spirit I mean you know it's
like and he could have to me he could
have been a heavyweight UFC champ if he
would have wanted to do that in his life
I mean what's he like two hundred to one
defeats or something like that he's not
ridiculous how do you some people from
this psycho trouble he 16 guys in one
day in one tournament he he got
submitted by the way one day he
submitted see submit at 16 guys and took
the title he's going into some boat
championships and won [__]
championships
I mean he's incredible I'm in and all
the Machado brothers have done that
stuff you know that would still you know
they all around the world they were
doing that stuff who does nothing but
Brazilian jiu-jitsu and then goes into
Samba and wins against a guy that's done
nothing but Zombo
I mean he got to be a special kind of
athlete you know to do that it's amazing
his resume is incredible and all those
guy mean Hicks on all those guys were
doing that stuff they were just we're
gonna rule the world
I mean I was and they did you know you
started mm we were discussing this yeah
and it's funny because I'm not here to
break your balls break anybody's balls
but the members of poison now there was
an original name before you came out
here yes
what was that Paris Paris yeah came out
here you like really
for comparison yeah no [__] poison
[__] laughs yeah it's so funny how the
members from you know your band used to
get into fisticuffs or one another yeah
like in 91 at the MTV Music Awards I
figured one day Ricky rapped and said
you know what before [__] go to Ricky
rocket said before [__] gets deep I'm
gonna get the martial arts just in case
things come over here I could [__]
people up and not feel guilty so you
joined because you know there was a how
many fights with it yes only sir but you
know what most of the time we're on each
other's sides we at the beginning I
always tell people this at the beginning
of our career for the first even 5 years
people don't know what to make of us
they want to either [__] us or fight us
I mean when we went into a town
literally we got in so many fights and
our record company didn't know how to
deal with it they suppressed everything
guns and roses they would you know they
just argue with somebody and they put in
the press also our record come they put
evidence and maybe it was for the best
who knows but but the reason I got into
martial arts seriously I mean always
loved Bruce Lee and that stuff but when
I came out here we had a scenario where
a guy tried to stab me and a guy with a
with a bumper off of a Volkswagen try to
stick Bobby doll right on the street on
Washington Boulevard and LA right right
there yeah yeah and I thought I was
gonna die that night and I swore to
myself I'm gonna learn how to defend
against the knife because I could have
died if a cop wouldn't have come around
the corner and they saw the cop that
wouldn't have happened the guy would
have stuck me and he was [__] up his
eyes or I mean he looked like I mean he
was gonna he was gonna get me and I get
freaked out just thinking about it cuz I
didn't know anything really back now I
mean well I took a couple karate classes
and I wrestled in school but I wasn't
gonna beat a guy with a knife who was on
drugs I wasn't gonna happen
and who knows I might not now either but
but I'd have a fighting chance now but
then I was just like you know AB right
at that moment I made that decision I'm
gonna learn something so when I did have
some money and some time I went after
cast Magda who was Danny and Asano's
assistant 4 years 15 years JKD guy Bruce
Lee stuff Filipino martial arts see lot
more Thai had that mix of martial arts a
lot of knife fighting that's what I went
for so for five years I did knife
fighting stick fighting all that kind of
stuff and then there was I'm telling you
my martial arts still no I want to hear
and then there was a guy that came in
and did a seminar with Harry Montoya let
me try that one more time
Hari mousey lot and it's a sort of a
ground game type of see lot and I want
that put me in touch with my wrestling
background a little bit and then I saw
voice crazy in the UFC and I went look
at this this is coming around full
circle it isn't just about standing up
and striking that I mean I feel
comfortable when I clench I feel
comfortable when I'm on the ground more
than one I'm not what am i doing trying
to just strike you know what I mean and
someone I got the opportunity to go to
the Machado brothers school I thought
I'd do find I got tapped out 14 times
that day I remember it like it was
yesterday
and I went dis is what I need to be and
I mean I just never looked back that was
17 years ago my first private that I
ever did was with John Joc and then I
started to train with annatto and an
Automag know and then I'd do the regular
classes and then sometimes I do privates
and then sometimes I do regular classes
and I did a combination of both all the
way and still I still do it that way I
still do privates you know and I still
do group class it just depends on my
time you know on a man and now I'm even
busier than I was then oddly enough I'm
semi-retired rock musician and I have
less time than I did then but
that's how it goes right when the other
retired yeah and you have children and
you were divorced remarried and I mean
you went through the last couple years
after I saw you on that flight like your
life changed dramatically one day yes
yes how did you feel when we're talking
about the rape allegation right yeah
back in we battle we would be oh god be
dead like if what happened you know what
that people need to like we'll get to
that what's that my [__] story it was
very weird and to this day I don't
completely understand who this person
really truly was I know quite a bit
about her from the private investigator
but okay so what happened was we did new
zealand auckland new zealand or not
Auckland Wellington New Zealand and it
was called Rock to Wellington a big
festival over there we played that and
it's like a for Tammy it's like a
two-hour drive to get to the airport
it's 14-hour draw flight and that you
know I mean it's like it kills you right
and I remembered Zac i sat with Zakk
Wylde and he got drunk passed out
finally good but we're in line right
away ox when we got off to get our bags
right and a guy came up and said I I
need to see you I need to take you to
the front here and that goes whoa it
looks like somebody's tour manager
pulled a favor and I'm like yeah that's
cool why I got to go to the front of the
line or they took me in a room and
handcuffed me and I went what what is
this about for two hours they would not
tell me what was going on and I had one
hand on my cell phone I'm texting my
tour manager until they took it from me
but at least I eat the text damn right
and so he came and tried to figure out
what was going on and they said Elliot
are LAPD will will talk to you when you
get here have you been in any problems
with anybody and bababang I'm like well
I got an argument with somebody I know I
I don't know the police came and started
to question me
have you had a situation with somebody
and I said well I had a former partner
that I was in the drum business with and
we got it had some words at NAMM and he
goes none you know this is criminal
mister you're under arrest for rape and
I went what like this some kind of
[__] joke exactly at this time you
know I was engaged okay you're in gay
and I mean I'm looking around for
cameras like I'm seriously thinking I'm
getting [__] with you know what I mean
like I mean I didn't you know and so
they took me and they started asking me
a bunch of questions and I didn't know
how to answer most of them because I
really seriously didn't know what the
[__] was going on I really didn't and
they asked me they said what names have
you gone by aliases and I said well you
know I've gone by a bunch of dumb names
ditches and all kinds of stuff you know
it hotels and he goes what about John
Minskoff and I went no I don't know that
man but I remembered it when he said it
to me I was like why was he cops an
estimate so we got a lawyer lawyer came
down I thought they were gonna extradite
me to Mississippi because it turns out
that this allegation came out of
Mississippi which we had played there
once that year but a different part of
the state we played in and it was in
Philadelphia Mississippi now if you do
some research on Philadelphia
Mississippi it's worth Mississippi
Burning happened by the way okay that's
the town that's the area okay for
reference so it's kind of a place that
is it's uh as it turns out it is a
there's a casino there and it's kind of
a destination you don't just pass by it
you got to like drive to it you know
what I mean I've never been there in my
life to this casino to this day and so I
didn't know what they're talking about
I'm like I don't know what the Silver
Star Casino is I don't know who John
Minskoff is I don't know so five o'clock
in the morning they cut me loose you
know the guy comes the cops come and go
you got to get yourself to Mississippi
and get that straight now I'm right
getting extradited I'm like I'm gonna go
be in a jail in Mississippi like this
ain't good
Anderson no no no you're out in the
[__] Street but you need to take care
of your [__] and I want okay fine I walk
out the door right and I'm like now what
do I do
I called my girlfriend she'd had taken
ten xanax to calm down couldn't drive
I'm in the middle of La somewhere trying
to figure out how to get home anyway I
get home and I start just data-mining
the name John Minskoff who was John
Minskoff I come up with a million thing
then all of a sudden I hit paydirt that
there was a John men's golf that had
been arrested okay for telling a
fifteen-year-old that he was a
photographer for Whitesnake and that he
would do the and in one of his
interviews after being arrested for it
he actually kidnapped the girl for three
days he went to jail for a period of
time and he said that him and his
friends used to always in pretend they
were different rock stars to try to get
laid
okay I went bingo this is gonna be the
[__] guy okay cuz it ain't me I
didn't rape anybody I've even been in
Mississippi except for one show which
was not in that part of the state like I
said so I told my lawyer right away I
said there was this guy okay and they
said okay we're gonna look him up in the
meantime you're doing a lie-detector
test right away and if it's good we're
gonna use the data we can't use it in
court
but if it's bad we're never gonna talk
about it I said okay I did the
lie-detector test which took all day
I've never done anything like that guy
called my lawyer and said this guy is
like flying colors telling the truth he
doesn't know anything about things you
know and so my lawyer was very happy
about that because he didn't want to
weigh in on it and so then he started to
track now in this John Minskoff got and
we hired a private investigator to go to
the Silver Star Casino and Philadelphia
Mississippi and figure out who this
person was so the best that we can put
it together after all this time was
there was a guy that was a piano player
and singer who was playing at that
casino told a girl there that he was me
okay and I don't know why I don't play
piano so I don't know this is the part I
can't put together okay
but maybe she was dumb I don't know but
there is video of her going into a room
with this guy and then later coming out
there was another guy that was in the
room too he walked out she said that was
Bret Michaels by the way so Brad was
there apparently too according to this
woman and that I ain't Lear aped her and
abused her and all this kind of stuff
and she filed three different times by
the way and they're doing everything
they can and so we ran
just a little dislodge istic Slyke like
let's pretend that I really wanted to go
to Philadelphia Mississippi find
somebody rape them and fly back to Los
Angeles okay how would all that work
okay so we put together this trajectory
of that day okay and that day by the way
I happen to be with my fiancee hoping
her pick out wedding dresses because
like you have to sign in it in one of
these places right so that was too many
afternoon so I would have had to flown
all night and driven driven like to out
like it was some ridiculous and I would
I would have had to go in like get it
done and get back on a flight that had
no delays and I mean it was like dude no
way you could even do it you know and
the District Attorney looked at it and
said I can't even indict this guy and
I'll indict [__] anybody but I can't
indict this guy it's not even the
hospital I back to Mississippi at all I
did not have to thank God you were smart
but it took like six weeks for the for
the DEA to get to my case so because he
had like murder cases and all this stuff
and he's listening to some testimonies
from not woman that was trying to make
money basically because what they found
out was that she had hired two different
civil attorneys because they knew they
weren't going to get me on read any real
charges because there wasn't anything I
didn't do anything I never matter in my
life but maybe they could twist my arm
hard enough that they could got other
lawyers to come in and try to get me to
just give them shut up
money and I said [__] nowhere I did
not I never met this person I've never
been in that part of the state I didn't
have anything to do is I never raped a
person in my life I got nothing to do
with this at all somebody is stealing my
identity and they're the ones that
either did it like actually raped her or
she just came up with a story because
her husband got wind of it now the
rafter Ronnie I don't know I think
because they were in cahoots her and the
husband did go to the police together
that much I know and I know he filed
chapter 11 a couple times he had a car
car line news car lot or something like
that I so to this day I still don't know
who the girl is I know her name but I've
never met her I've never seen what she
looks like
and I'd never been to that casino and
for the life of me why I would get
picked and singled out is beyond me
I was just [__] unlucky you know and
a man I think Rocco loved was on at the
time and maybe if she would have picked
Brett it would have been too obvious
because he was right there on the TV so
let's pick somebody else from the TV
from the band the same band I don't know
I I mean this is all guesses I really
don't know what her line of thinking was
or maybe it was a guy that told her and
she believed them or maybe it was so I
don't know I don't get crazy plays off a
plane get pulled over and to be
basically I mean you know another term
is able to charge you which I don't like
County told Mississippi extradited you
would have to go over them make bail
which you was a man because I spent
every cent I made to pay my lawyer and
more oh yeah yeah yeah you know and the
other thing was is that it made it so
hard for me because we're getting ready
to go overseas to do some other shows
too and you know they don't like you
leaving the country when you're under
investigation like that I remember I was
in a target looking for something I
don't know
and this woman who you could tell she
was like my age group somebody that
would like poison you know any man kind
of rock look and she her little girl
with her and I look over and she
recognises Who I am and grabs a little
girl's hand and beelines it the other
direction because she saw me and she
heard about that charge that broke my
heart more than almost anything too for
somebody to actually think that I would
do that and to be treated like that you
know any because that ain't me I think I
dude I've never raped anybody and and
and and I was coming out with my first
signature symbol and stores wouldn't
carry it and I mean that you you are
definitely guilty until proven innocent
and a note and worse now like you said
you were starting to talk about it just
a second ago
you better [__] believe it nowadays
dun dun whether it's true or not no once
they read it on print it's [__] true
like that's what's crazy about those
type of allegations that once people
it's like have you ever written
something about yourself like a book
no I plan on doing that long wait till
you write the part of being in
Pennsylvania and the stuff you and Ricky
duh you and Brett did and now you hooked
up with my kin bah bah bah when you read
it never mind thinking about it once you
read it there's times you have to put
your pen down taking classes off of a
while I can't believe I did that you
know you just said before about the
schlepping when you first got here yeah
who does that [__] right people with a
dream buy the [__] you don't know how
you won't know how strong cuz I'm trying
to write write a book and there's days I
have to take a day off from what I wrote
today before and read because whenever I
thought about it it hit me a little
harder which everything right sure and
that's the problem that we have today
that listen we started you know the meat
to product things started a crazy thing
now so now that guys are walking around
scared you know women walking around
[__] skid and there's gonna be a lot
of fake allegations in
next couple years well as it turns out I
mean I talked to a lot of police and you
know so many rape allegations aren't
true to begin with which really sucks
for the people that truly have been
raped right okay because you know they
they have it hard enough as it is trying
to come forward okay and the me to thing
I think it's I think it's great
but now people it's human nature are
gonna take advantage of that and try to
make a name for themselves with it
now I I wouldn't want it if I was a
woman I wouldn't want to be a me-too
person you know unless it really [__]
happened to me you know and I wish these
women would realize that when they do
that and it's not true they're doing
such a disservice to the truly to the
people that truly were taken advantage
of you know what I mean because you know
the you shouldn't do that really I mean
Weinstein or what was you know my
saviors name why yeah I mean come on Lee
Harvey no yeah [__] shooter I mean
you know I mean it's now come on you
know it's we can't get away you
shouldn't get away with that [__] but
you know at the same time people should
not be able to get away with faking it
either that's [__] - you know what I
mean God we're in the [__] where is
truth in this world anymore I mean it's
it's just like I don't like to get on
very apolitical because our audience I
do not like separating our audience
because we have people from all walks of
like that like our music and the thing
that brings us together is our music
okay and our love for music our love for
a good time and that what that feels
like when you when you play or enjoy
music together so the last thing I like
to do is bring politics into my world
because it does nothing but destroy it
but like with this March that just
happened
the thing I like about it more than
anything is at least it has people
talking about that subject and what it's
done is it's made people show their ass
on both sides of the aisle I've seen
people on both sides of that argument
and I'm sitting there gone and I cannot
believe that you send that on both sides
I'm like I'm there's people I only want
to be friends with because it
doesn't even matter what the politics
are I'm just sitting there gone I can't
believe you just [__] said that
that's how you really feel how are your
children don't wreck a few minor I have
my girls 5 and my boys 8 he'll be 9 in a
month I gotta ask you from your heart
yeah you worry I mean my school was
locked down a few weeks ago so I took
him drop them off at school right and
then I took my little girl she goes to a
preschool took her to preschool
I get the call just as I'm getting back
in my car from dropping her off
I had to beeline it back to Jude school
and by the time I got there the police
were not letting us in not letting them
out and I'm sitting there going what the
[__] is going on here you know what I
mean and and a lot of parents are
freaking out and I'm like look don't
freak out they are doing the best job
they can do right now I mean you got
cops wall the wall here right but nobody
knew what was going on and they're like
why can't they tell us what's going on
I'm like they can't because as soon as
you do that then the criminal changes
their story that's why you know so I get
that and but it was so frustrating not
to be able to just go [__] it I can I
know that 15 feet away that my little
boy is in there and I can just go grab
him like why can't I just go do that
right now you know any man that's a very
frustrating feeling but it was all this
you know seat monkey-see monkey-do stuff
you know somebody else is doing it
they're getting overriding then I'll get
notoriety if I do it too
what was the cause of the lockdown it
was a kid who's 15 years old he was at
one of their older kids obviously and he
told somebody at school that the next
day he was gonna come in and shoot up
the school and then he didn't show up
for school the next day and so they went
look for him and he wasn't at home I
wasn't at home and he hadn't checked
into school so they don't know where
he's at you know him in and so that's
where it all came from and I don't know
any more than that yet he's gonna be I
know he had to face a judge probably I
think this week
so we'll see we'll see what his
motivation I mean maybe he was just
kidding maybe whatever but you know
people need to realize you cannot kid
about that [__] you have a five-year-old
like I do you're 56 correct yeah
Jesus she was slinging bacon 51 like
yeah cuz I had mercy at 50 you know I
knocked my wife up legally at 49 but I
had mercy at 49 a month why she's
January 8 I think I'm February 19th you
know sometimes I wonder that like is
there should be like you know you
shouldn't knock somebody up when they're
too young like should you be a point
where you shouldn't knock somebody up
when you're old enough
I mean maybe seriously think about I'm
gonna be an old guy by the time my kids
get out of high school I'm an old guy
now you know so sometimes I feel bad
about Yankee women today's America the
55 year old and 60 they're looking 45
I'm gonna guy like new trains three
times a week and one of the toughest
things you could do and you're going at
it with Renato who's no [__] white
belt you know so I believe the same
thing to I when I first came here I got
infatuated with the calmly buck and I
forgot about everything even though I
came from a martial arts background and
lift some weights I just you know the
lighting that you go to [__] your Mel's
or Pink's and you get a sandwich and
french fries and Mexican it was falling
the [__] pounds and then I lost
weight and then I joined finally joined
you Jitsu which I was I never want to
touch a man's foot and I never wanted
man's ass in my face I was always a
karate guy kickboxing when I went down
and watching Eddie was doing I'm like
listen the first time Rikki Rockett puts
his ass in my face to try to get a comb
or I tap when I shoot him in the [__]
neck
like that's how I thought like you can
do whatever you want just don't put
chassé in my face I love it I walked in
there and got this addiction to just
jiu-jitsu even though I'm [__] hard
more Rikki Rockett because it doesn't
matter my first seven years economy I
was mumbling stumbling along it's like
a drummer and you've been playing for
two years on setting up a band signed
yet you got to get you got to go from
level a the level B right
sometimes it takes time and I'm patient
this is what Tom MIDI taught me to be
patient the whole thing it just keeps
showing up yeah if you keep going to
that Matt just keep going you'll get
drilled for a 2 years 3 I still got beat
up today well it's like I'm figuring out
my vlog like I finally started a YouTube
what made you do all this though I
started doing the vlog because I'm Mike
out on stuff I love cameras I love
drones motorcycles motorcycle gear all
that [__] and I'm like if I do a vlog I
can talk about it because every day I'm
going on YouTube watching some you know
some guy talk about why I should get
this drone or that's a jacket socks or
don't get this helmet or you know and
and it helps I mean it helps you make a
decision you know otherwise you're just
reading ads right and and I thought I
just geek out on stuff so much I want
people to see that's why I named it you
know Rikki Rockett vlog drummer etc yeah
I'm a drummer but it's the other part
that you don't know about all this [__]
that I'm interested in and that I you
know I love gear under a gear head I
love all that [__] you know any man who
gave me the name Rikki Rockett well my
name is Richard you know so Ricky was
you know came right along with it but
rocket I what I worked for a hairdresser
and my job okay it was just a summer job
okay and my job was to greet the patron
okay wash everything in the scene you
know all the perm rods the combs that
all that stuff clean up sweep hair just
really the [__] job is what what it was
take the person's code where was this
NPA in central Pia and Billy Campbell
heterosexual by the way just taught me
how to talk to people and how how to
move really really quickly and he said
he never saw anybody moved their ass
that fast I was like a [__] rocket
and I would seriously just
you know he'd say mr. so-and-so is
coming in today he likes playboy and he
likes a ham sandwich with you know
whatever and then you know so and I
wouldn't run out and I'd get it and
everything would be ready for that
client and I'd get ready for the next
client and I made his life easier and so
I got called the Rocket Man because I
was just paying bambam you know any man
and I learned a lot about life and
hustling by that because the more I did
it the better tips I got better tips I
got the better more I could party and
the more drums I could buy so that was
uh and then I really fell in love with
that business I was like man you can
like be around girls all day I don't
have to be out in the heat like layin
tars like that like I don't want to do
that right and so I turn around I went
to beauty school and got my license you
did culture yeah and so I and I was like
should I get a barber license should I
get there no this is all pre Paris oh
yeah oh this is Dori well it was during
a little bit part of it I was always in
bands I've been in bands since I was
like 12 okay I always wanted to play but
I had to make a living too you know any
man and I didn't know if that was gonna
work out for me or not you know any man
I anytime I could pick music over
anything
I picked music over anything over
anything literally you know that's why I
think it took me so long and wife to
have a family it's because I chose it
over family yeah I felt like there
wasn't enough room in my life to do both
and I didn't meet the right I thought I
didn't meet the right person and all
that kind of stuff really it was me that
wasn't ready but but I'd like to say
that I had didn't meet the right person
I was just trying to get laid that's all
it was yes all the gear well just let's
pretend just to fall off with Bret
Michaels
I mean I'm get [__] every night I just
hang up by the bathroom and watch them
cry then getting to meet Bret let me let
me talk to you let me show you something
that was you just the Bret fall off mmm
just I hang out like do you know Bret
I kind of know him did you talk to him a
little before me I really like to meet
them well you know I usually do it but
Brett wants me to try out for this bike
I was gonna ask you about your little
girl you like me or highlight you is
you're the [__] Savage you saw the
other side of life from this woman who
allegedly said you raped her to all
those years on the road I mean I'm sure
you went home a lot of nights and held
your head and said what the [__] just
happened you know what I just say I live
in the same boat as you do I mean my
little girl is my world you know well
you know what it I always say this that
Lucy my little girl wasn't you know
Jude's a miracle obviously too but Lucy
I think came along in my life when I
least expected it and I think that
there's like some lesson in her way the
guy was waiting for mercy what I I was I
was with my wife for 13 years one that
you think I like I expected mercy God my
wife is stabbed and that was the day I
probably I had the surgery and I started
doing squats drinking protein powder and
between the GNC protein powder and the
squats it rejuvenated this and that
wasn't my way I can listen to this it's
the GNC commercials I go to GNC still
because after all he is the whey protein
got my wife knocked up between the
squats and the wave that I think I
didn't squash and the testosterone up so
I got my wife is eating stopped drinking
whey protein I just drank it before I
came now I even text Ricky's and I'll be
there in seven can I sit where you are
you get in between us so he was saying
how do you mean the drum no no I just
think that Lucy came along like I still
not sure what the lesson is completely
but I think it has a lot to do with I
mean I've always respected women honest
to god I I know a lot of people say Oh
give me a [__] break
but really and but I think she's taken
it to another level I want people to
treat my little girl with respect have I
treated every girl with the same kind of
respect I want to see her treated with I
don't know I wanted to get laid right so
which is normal and you know there's
nothing weird about that but did I just
like like is there something that I I'm
gonna learn and I think I am learning it
that I I've never it's like when you
have a little girl and I think you're
gonna agree with this you endear
somebody it it's the most endearing you
can be to somebody with nothing else
attached to it look at that
who wouldn't make me wear this yeah and
the best part about it is she's been
gone for a week she's not here she's not
here oh she gave me this
with the look in her eye it was like it
took her like like somebody said to me
that saying who made that for you you
little girl like I know they tell you
stripper yeah my little [__] girl me
[Laughter]
she like the teacher told me in school
she's like she made you a matching
necklace ensemble bracelet so I got out
of wearing the bracelet but she gave me
the thing you know the feeling yeah you
know the feeling you know heart stops I
mean I could be on the computer deep
deep but I got Judas Priest hell-bent
for leather on I'm answering Ricky on
Twitter I'm sending an email back I'm
making notes in the notebook and should
just come in the room like get on my lap
and go Daddy
put on octonauts and that's it no no
you're doing like whatever I was
thinking my you will cry and do
something and come over and hug me and
I'll be like I'll lose it and my
girlfriend a boo you know she's working
here right now that's how my like says
to me yeah yes I do
like this far away I know I will come
from the other side and go you know I
took her at if I'm in town listen we're
gone so much you know on the weekends
that when I'm home Saturday I catch a a
line I am kickboxing class I got out at
10:15 I'd get to meet the boys
so without the THC I go home I go home I
pick her up and I take her and the
mother for breakfast you know a pancake
restaurant what and then I dropped the
mother off and I take aren't you glad he
just didn't say like I'm sweating out
the math well good Friday so I didn't
stop and get edibles to pay off I was
gonna stop and get us a 200 edibles body
of Christ I appreciate it do you realize
Easter is on April Fool's Day this year
yes like what I'm gonna like wrap like
eggs yeah I mean grapes and and wrap and
give it to my kid and say hey that's all
I got April Fool's I mean you know wow
that's weird but anyway it is what it is
I've never been like I was in like never
the fun holiday for me Easter it was
okay but it's like eat some chocolate
you have dinner and now what
everything's closed you know you know
it's not supposed to be fun when you get
older supposed to be more serious you
know what I mean but I just got home
with my wife and my daughter to
Tennessee this weekend and I thought
about it you know for Easter the whole
thing where they live I survived two
days well you live in Tennyson I live
here okay
where my wife is from the city where
she's from
it's what's in its Sun it's close to
Milan Tennessee okay it's a little like
20 minutes from there yeah my girls from
now Thursday
please fried chicken which is the only
reason why I would get on that [__]
plane like if I got it it's for Lee's my
fried [__] chicken
it is delicious it's not that Nashville
spicy [__] right this is just good old
fried chicken made by good ol African
American old-school black people they're
all overweight and then saying they got
gloves on they got flour all over their
faces but they thought I'd have pried
the chicken they I know and I felt like
going around but again it's like I'm
gonna get stuck there for five days with
them or whatever and it's my my wife's
tonight white for me it's my wife's time
like when I'm there she's worried about
me like what am I thinking
yeah she's trying to appease me and I'm
like don't just wake up your mom and dad
you know I go for a walk I smoke a joint
I put an iPod on I'm [__] happy I
mean there's no jiu-jitsu there but
you're married right married yeah okay
nine years ten years yeah I've been with
her for 17 and the I did a movie for
next once and years ago and he called me
in with the night before and I said some
dirty [__] and but my scene was with Don
Johnson and him and I got stuck in a
room because we'd have to I met him I
met him yeah and he at the time I don't
know how old I was when people will
congratulating them cuz he just had a
kid man go in the back of my mind oh you
creepy selfish [__] having a kid
over 50 what do you think dr. Laura
talked about that one time whatever but
a Don Johnson I met at a wedding
John Brenkus wedding who's a very famous
attorney that poison used he was also
Michael Jackson's attorney I met Michael
Jackson that same night the one and only
time I met Michael Jackson who was very
cool by the way
very cool I was introduced to Michael
Jackson through Quincy Jones and all
this told me ain't never I'm kidding but
it sounds like a joke
I'm about ready like I'm just like
bringing up [__] names but Don
Johnson was there and I talked to him
for maybe three minutes very nice guys
talking to other people now when he went
to leave the the reception he went
around and said hey it was nice meeting
you deck hey Ricky it was nice meeting
you I hit Jane nice man he remembered
every [__] person's name that he met
that he had never met before it blew me
away
blew me away I said I want to be able to
do that I still can't do it well that
that's funny because when I worked with
him I had her over Miami Vice stuff and
stuff and it was one of the best
morning's of my life I treated him like
one of the guys I had known we started
talking about movies next thing you know
I looked up I go when I was a Galena
street having a cocktail 1984 and I
heard a bunch of yelling and screaming
and it was Don Johnson that they heat of
Miami Vice he was living in Aspen I was
living in Snowmass Village I was at a
bar in Aspen and I'm ever hearing all
this crap I guess he walked into the
wrong [__] bar whether it was like 90
women and they chased him out all you
could see is his bodyguard and Don
Johnson running down the street [__] up
by 85 white [__] loafers and you know
all that [__] don't you wish you could
get away with wearing white [__]
loafer he used to wear those like that's
let's bring that [__] yeah we don't
stock some yeah no sob with socks for
one day my feet smell like oh yeah but
not [__] sneakers with no sighs I
know you gotta go what do you think of
this because this is what the important
can you believe when you started this
band Paris in 1986 was it what we
started no we moved out here in 84 we
started the band and like I mean Bret
and I had we had been on another band
before that what became poison and we
were doing all the work and the other
two guys just were not working it they
they had an excuse for everything and so
that's why we started poison and the
we started it with the idea in mind that
we wanted to see or we wanted to be
everything that we wanted to see in a
band do you know what I'm saying yes yes
we wanted the music to be there we
wanted people to look cool we wanted it
to be a exciting on stage that the the
dynamic on stage all that stuff we
created we set out to create that as
fans like as a fan what do I want to say
and that's what we pursued with poison
we couldn't do it with the other guys so
we tried to make it happen in PA but it
was limited like I said you know we're
able to go to Maryland and play shows
and things like that and then start but
it was happening here this is where rock
and roll was happening
heavy metal all that was happening in
Los Angeles there was fertile ground for
what we were doing it was not happening
back east not that much a little bit
there was some good bands that came out
of there of course Kix is amazing
Rothschild America I mean there were
some great bands that came out from
there the dead end kids all these great
bands but the timing to our age all that
stuff we just couldn't make it fly back
there you know and a man it was always
gonna stay just at this level you know
we wanted we were shooting higher than
them who does love the songwriting for
you guys like the freeze-out together we
would get no we would get in just like a
garage band you know we got in a
rehearsal room or you know we lived on
Washington Avenue we you know was just a
room basically we just get together and
start playing you know somebody come up
with hair come up with a breath or I'm
in the mood for this and would you know
do you ever do this and you ever hear
this song and I had this but you know
and we just work on it together like
that I love that I love we we are
literally a garage band you know in a
man that figured out how to take it to
an arena level I I really honestly
stimulus for that that was my next
question I mean in 1984 when you came
out here I mean what would what were you
thinking what was gonna be the final
result we had Kim Fowley was interested
nos Kim Fowley I don't know if you know
who he is was he produced The Runaways
he's famous for The Runaways but he's
kind of like an idol maker there's not
many of those guys left in the world
anymore especially in rock Malka
MacLaren's probably the last living idol
maker but you know he wrote a lot of
songs alley oop and all this stuff back
in the day but he would create bands and
concepts and try to turn it into
something and he fell in love with what
we were doing he had heard a demo and
said you guys got to come out so we try
to work with him and he said something
to me one time our whole band actually
he said people do things around rock and
roll they will never do in normal life
and I'll never forget that because he
was so right he was crazy he died a
couple years ago he was crazy and he was
a very underhanded guy but he was very
brilliant and some of the things he said
it just stuck with me all these years
but he sort of taught us a little bit
how to survive in LA cuz it's a
different vibe out here I mean it is and
it you know you have to if you're not if
you're not hustling you're getting
hustled I mean that's LA that is [__]
how I but did you see like a rain this
[__] I mean in the beginning was that
what you guys were thinking did I see
what arenas I mean hell no [__] no we
didn't know that you just guys wanted to
get signed and maybe open up for
Aerosmith you would've been good with
that we were very luck I mean the first
tour we got was Quiet Riot
we went Alec wire right now they were on
their way down unfortunately at that
time and they weren't doing that well
but they were still playing big clubs
some you know some smaller arenas some
theatres a lot of clubs at that time but
it was big time for us dude
yeah and that was like our shot and we
went out there and we we did everything
we could on that tour when our record
came out and we released cry tough it
didn't do that well cry tough is a great
song and I believe in those words you
know and I mean the lyrics to that song
somebody put it in their review book as
a matter of fact it somebody showed me
some
go but it didn't light up the phones at
MTV man it just didn't work and so the
record company said you know unless you
got a tour or something we're gonna have
to go back to the drawing board and so
we sign that's when we managed to
finagle the rat tour rat those guys
liked us we were creating enough buzz
without a successful single that they
wanted to put us out on the road what
year was a that was 86 that was uh I was
86 approximately lay it down tour yeah I
think so yeah yeah I think it was the
second record like right well the first
one was rat and roll no first they
released a four-song EP fur right right
with a woman man by the house then they
released an album then the second one
whatever the [__] but because of getting
the rat tour enigma records said we'll
give you another single but we're not
gonna give you that kind of money for a
for a video again because it didn't work
and we said just give us a video it will
make it work so it was a very
inexpensive video which is why talk to
me has no continuity to it it's like we
don't have time to make all this have
all this perfect film attic continuity
we're just gonna make it a [__] party
like we're having a party we're doing
this video there's the cameras there's a
camera guys put them all in it's all fun
let's just do it you know what I mean
and it I think that energy translated
because when that video came out on MTV
people really connected with it they
connected with the fun aspect of the
song the fact that we were just really
really wanting to take fun rock and roll
to another level you know what I mean we
were living an absolute [__] at that
time so you fantasize about what would
it be like if we were playing arenas and
we did have all the things that we
wanted we'd write songs about how we
wanted our life to be you know what I
mean not how it was but how we wanted it
to be and we weren't gonna like bathe in
our own [__] and write all these shitty
lyrics some people took did it that way
but we didn't we were like fantasize I'm
gonna be positive we're gonna
and that song just connected and and
it's one of when I did meet Michael
Jackson back to that for a second he
said that was one of the funnest videos
he's ever seen that was pretty cool so
when somebody else would cut us down as
he'll poison sucks dislike Laurent
Michael Jackson loved our videos oh [__]
David Bowie likes our video [__] yeah a
lot of great videos I mean MTV it's a
shame to see that I grew up on MTV you
know when I grew up on [__] MTV and
now I turn it on its some [__]
pregnant chick and she can't afford the
kids you married the brood oh I thought
you know what it's a we I think poison
was really meant for that that medium it
was a perfect time in all worth of yeah
I mean Brett works great and that medium
I think all of us you know Cece is great
in front of it you know right up front
in front of the camera you know I mean
it's just I think synergistically our
band just worked so well on the video
medium it just and at that time they
approached videos like they were little
movies I mean Marty call her and all
these amazing video directors they went
after it like they were doing a film
remember by the time they kind of
smugglers blues and the Glenn Frey yes
was blues yeah that was a short [__]
fell God forever came out whenever she
was come on
Aerosmith with the videos they were
making forget about it I still remember
sitting at home with our buddies 1982
because Aldo novo was the midnight
Louise he vote that guy's a good guitar
player he's a great guitar and I heard
that he is later he's written like they
like he's still around writing songs for
fat people
yeah boy just he's the real deal when
does this tour start now we start
may 18th here in Irvine and we finished
now in Florida I want to say Miami I
believe don't quote me on that on the
first of May or not that for a job first
of July so we go May to July it's a
quick tour but it's big cities it's uh
you know we're hitting it hard
it's gonna be awesome I mean original
lineup everybody you know cheap tricks
out there with us
pop Evil's a great band I mean it's it's
gonna be a blast man it's a what a way
to kick off spring you know Ricky next
time I have you I want you to come on
earlier so we could talk alone I hate
when people into traffic oh yeah time is
it's 3:45 I don't want to get out of
here I just want to tell you I love you
dawn my heart ever since I may be but a
gentleman you know the jujitsu thing you
inspired me that day with Danny in the
Sun I'll sweet you are and I know you
will you've been through and you're a
[__] soldier and I love you thank you
always have an open door here and you
know we'll suppose tomorrow to know you
want ice I just I want to do what two
hours just talking about arm bars I know
you you love it then next time we'll do
symbols you know if you know if I felt
like I could keep everybody in my vlog
I've done some jujitsu stuff it doesn't
get the most response you know people
like it you know what I mean why not
this week people don't get it the same
way I wish I want to do a film so bad
just so you know about jujitsu and
grappling so the people some way for
people to really really understand
what's going on because I mean I was
like yeah who is at the middleweight
champion right now the black dude who's
a man yes he was talking he did an
interview and he's talking about Demian
Maia where it's like Demian Maia
sometimes will act like he's getting
beat up so that they'll go in for the
kill when they go in for the kill that's
when he grabbed ahold of his oh okay
and these are the types of things that
people the average person has no clue
about they don't know what's going on in
the mind of of grapplers you know
punching is a little more obvious you
know you swing and you hit the guy okay
we're grappling it's so subtle
you'd move your hip this way you lean
the weight this way
[__] you know what I mean Hicks on calls
it invisible jiu-jitsu all the stuff
that happens that isn't obvious to the
naked eye and I would love to do a film
or some special or a documentary that
really concentrates on getting people to
understand what is going on maybe in
slow motion maybe with narrative maybe a
combination of both but I'd like to talk
to you about what does the vlog you're
released ID I'm on vlog 13 number 13
already so I have 13 vlogs already on
your YouTube page it's Rikki Rockett
Rikki right and wrong song and you
release the blogs would usually on
Wednesdays but sometimes I do at Tuesday
it depends on the kids yes your
permission for some is it okay not this
week coming the following week if I pay
magno and come down and you teach me a
move on Cameron we put it on the blog do
it [__] yeah yeah we come over I'll be
more than happy to do I will teach you
the rock star robots real quick and I'll
get you out of here Austin Money Ball
schmock to Steven Cruz bobbler Lingus I
love you Barrow Yaxley Matt gorgeous
Cheri row back Danny Porter and Steve
Robbins listen you always got to eat and
you know me we opened up a blue apron
blue apron is offering our listeners $30
off your first delivery when it comes to
dinner let blue apron take care of the
planning and shopping while you do the
cooking and the evening all right you'll
enjoy delicious meals like popcorn
chicken with Swiss chili cabbage slaw
and cumin spice wonton noodles with
vegetables and peanuts on the table in
30 minutes or less with the incredible
ingredients and chef design recipes blue
apron lets you see what the power of
food can be listen they deliver it fresh
proportionate ingredients and you get a
step by step little card the cook can be
done in under 45 minutes and the menu
changes weekly based on what the season
and designed by blue aprons in the house
julen every team all right do me a favor
check out this week's menu look at this
beautiful thing seared salmon with lemon
lime neh and freaking zucchini and dates
were you nuts
human spiced wonton noodles with
vegetables and peanuts seared steaks
with lemon parmesan kale and roasted
potatoes and his double in my work oh oh
took a Rashi popcorn chicken with sweet
chili Cabbage Patch listen you don't
even you can't even you have a hard time
making an egg and now you're making
recipes like this don't do me a favor
check out this week's menu like I told
you fill out the information and I'm
gonna get your $30 off at blue apron
comm slash Joey just go to blue apron
coms last you know he pressing Joey on
the checkout and I'm making [__] $30 off
your first order you know why cuz blue
apron is a better way to cook number two
let me tell you something I'm no Mickey
Stallone you know I'm saying
I'm just a true-blue type of guy well I
tell you something I tell you something
Tony and me on these is the way to go
well I go to jujitsu I got me undies on
when I got sweats I got me undies on
it's not only I tell you they use the
lensing micromo down their underwear and
then the softest things in the world
it's not all that stuff not every month
they change patterns and you get
different designs it's not that that
they have a hundred percent satisfaction
money-back guarantee and me and these
guarantees you'll love their undies or
you get their money back you know what
it is that Point Blank [__] serious
they're the best underwear out in the
market they shape your balls they keep
you dry there's no [__] owners they
pull the sweat away from your skin and
that's how good they are plain and
[__] simple now today right now stop
[__] around with you should be [__]
on the west me on these has a great
offer for my listeners and for any of my
first times purchases when you purchase
any me on these you'll get 20% off and
free shipping how's that one for you you
can't get that deal nowhere me and these
are so sure you'll love the underwear
they're gonna offer you hundred-percent
satisfaction guarantee
if you don't love your first pair bad
you get a full refund it's a no-brainer
get 20% off your fit your first pair of
the
was comfortable underwear you ever
[__] put on plain and simple you know
I'm your uncle Joey I'm family go to me
on these calm right now
pick out a beautiful [__] pair pick
one out for your girlfriend I'm gonna
give you 20% off free shipping and a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
just by going to me on these comm slash
Joey that's me on these comm slash Joey
a better way to go you know I'm saying
don't forget I'm at the ice house April
14th and I'm at the funny bone 4/20
weekend thank you very much for coming
on Ricky it's been a [__] blast I've
been wanting to have you on for two or
three years and you made my [__] week
have a great [__] weekend I think you
want to tell these people just until I
love you I like [__]
stay black baby let's close up with some
put some poison here thank you again
thank you
this is us
[Music]